first at the moment v80 on hospitality and tourism is charged at 20% so I've decided for the next six months to cut fat on food accommodation and attractions eaten or hot takeaway food from restaurants cafes and pubs accommodation in hotels B&BS campsites and Caravan sites attractions like cinemas theme parks and zoos all these and more will see that reduced from next Wednesday until January the 12th from 20 percent to 5 percent this is a 4 billion pound catalyst for the hospitality and tourism sectors benefiting over a hundred and fifty thousand businesses and consumers everywhere or helping to protect 2.4 million jobs